Déjà
de son professeur
s
[Musique]
ré
[Applaudissements]
et l'Uruguay
et déjà
[Applaudissements]
et bon
Merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
si tu sais
Oui
de nouveau
[Applaudissements]
d'ailleurs
[Musique]
l'ESA
h quand tu
comme
à la voiture
bien
[Applaudissements]
bon
Oui
mais quand
ne sois pas meilleur
ou l'Inde
pour toujours
[Applaudissements]
je
de sortie
[Applaudissements]
l'approche des 23 cibles
vous ne pouvez pas écrire
[Applaudissements]
une
[Musique]
avec une
c'est le foot
[Musique]
moi non
c'est triste
un
[Applaudissements]
oh
je
nous devons utiliser la souris
un
et il avait raison
à moi si
et si
oh
l'hiver
[Applaudissements]
avant que
[Musique]
et si
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
plutôt en transition
oh
la fonction
et aide
[Applaudissements]
Alors
Soit
Oui
oh
donne moi
à profiter
bon
[Applaudissements]
regarder
européen
oh
de la nourriture
et tout ça
[Applaudissements]
un exemple
5 laissez-passer
[Musique]
comme
[Applaudissements]
précis
c'est très facile
l'amour
Oui
[Applaudissements]
ne pas
et voilà
bien
si non
[Musique]
Onze
pour cela
me le
[Applaudissements]
mais jamais
je
[Applaudissements]
ce son
Oui oui
Lien
m
à la fois dans l'habituel
le compteur
oh
Facile
[Applaudissements]
mais
Mieux payé de tes mains que moi
[Applaudissements]